[Music]
good morning you want to talk about
yesterday's massage experience I thought
I went to hell and came back what
happened
those people are horrible I'm never
going there again do you remember that
time that we had a massage and then you
were giggling your ass off when the guy
was destroying the balls of my feet oh I
guess karma came back or you prayed or
something cuz you you seemed perfectly
fine whereas the three girls all of us
we were dying no it hurt like when I
when I was doing it myself it hurt
really bad it's called it's like it's
the same thing like when they try to
tell kids that they're doing well they
call them stupid so it's the same thing
with pain so every time there's pain in
the body they want to give you more pain
so you feel better yeah that's it agency
you're supposed to wear does it fire
versus fire yeah it's the dumbest thing
on earth if you want to take out the
burning bush go add some oil
[Music]
how was I must email Silvana Nima's so
we're here today at a place called
addiction aquatic development and inside
here there's a huge sushi bar and it's a
stand standing sushi bar and we're here
early in the morning because it heard
that it's gonna be really busy Rudy
there's already like a whole roll of
people here um I'm not sure exactly what
this place is but a lot of my friends
told me that it's really good sushi is
fresh and yummy and cheaper than other
places so we're here to check it out so
this is some sort of miso soup I don't
know what's inside it obviously because
I don't speak Chinese or read Chinese I
don't know what's going on so I'm just
gonna give it a go
oh my god I don't know what that is does
it make your macro there's a fatty fish
oh that's amazing
like in the soup you can see like these
little like the pools of the fish fat in
there and that's like the collagen on
the fact from the fiction that kind of
melted away into the soup super amazing
oh sorry guys but we're gonna end this
really quickly because this is a
fast-paced type of restaurant that we're
gonna have to do and so we're gonna try
all these and give you guys comments of
how we fell about that was probably one
of the best meals I've ever had in terms
of sushi and the funny thing is I've had
it in Taiwan now I'm sorry that we
couldn't really give you guys extra
footage about what we were eating
because we were on the go it was a
standing sushi restaurant and that's not
really the milieu of the place so let me
just give you a breakdown what we had so
let's talk about the prawns brining
salty sweet delicious we also had
another type of Evie which was it wasn't
cooked it was raw super sweet as well
the head fat was amazingly delicious we
had a 2 total which was super delicious
as well then we had a salmon EGD with
that and then we also had squid and the
squid was actually something that was
very surprising for me a lot of people
don't like squid because it's actually
very slimy but they definitely very
unique to it they actually put a little
oil over it and then they charred it
over with a blowtorch now just as a
heads up if you guys are expecting this
to be a huge fish market like the one in
Japan it's not when I walked in I was a
little bit disappointed because all you
saw was this huge like tubs of different
types of crabs which is amazing in and
of itself but it wasn't what I was
expecting but make sure that you go to
the standing sushi bar inside it's gonna
blow your socks away I'm not even sure
if that's an American saying it's going
to blow your tote it's going to blow
your toenails off your feet it in your
mouth and travelers tip my friends bring
cash you cannot use car here it's only
cash thank me later
Wow get these cans was going
[Music]
here she goes
keep going don't give up I believe in
you don't embarrass yourself in front of
all of Taiwan don't you don't you don't
you for you don't you get back up you
get back up there and here she goes
again
first she uses her left arm then the
right one wraps her foot around to go
above the top show us your strength
woman show us as if your child was on
top and they were screaming for your
name yes
look at us she's gonna do it I believe
in you there if you were a man your
penis would be crushed on that bar but
you're not good very good yes how does
it feel
no we didn't think this through did we
everywhere I go I see my child you are
my child son come to your father come
come to your father come to your father
so we're out of cafe right now just sit
down in a nice cool area to try the
scallion pancake out I can tell you I
have not been so hyped to try food in my
life I this dude she's right they were
teaching that's exactly what he was
doing the dish
I don't know which one's mine but the
scouting ticket that I thought I got it
with cheese ham and eggs and also basil
right and it's a Taiwanese basil which I
never heard of so oh my god
smells so savory just pan-fried over a
hot flat skillet crispy on the outside
delicious egg on the inside is fluffy
from the way he touched
holy Frick just like an ultimate savory
bite to me this is what street food
really should be about I know that a lot
of you guys make like dining food which
I like to I think it's great but
something about streets of the headsets
like this is heartwarming tastes like it
fills your soul finally a Chinese
pancake rock rashon breakfast sandwich
had a baby and flavor [ __ ] each other is
so [ __ ] good
there it is you know focus there wasn't
like dad's innovation the pancake is so
freakin good
[Music]
Julia what the hell are you doing here I
had no idea you were a mango model so we
finally got our shaved ice it took a
while the line was freaking long
apparently place is popular as hell
Becky recommended this place to us here
we have some mango pieces we have
Italian panna cotta on top and with some
delicious shaved ice
that's good
well that's freaking good this is like
perfect for a hot humid day you know one
is still popular in Taiwan every Taiwan
these buttons should be here and live
here in the store and of course as every
good boyfriend should do you can't just
feed yourself you got to feed the
girlfriend as well
what do you think
it's good right how good is that that's
frickin good
now before we hit the night market we
decided that we're a bit hungry even
after all that food w8 and Muriel really
really wants me to try out this co-op
out place pop out if you guys don't
remember from the previous video is that
that that white bun with the pork with
the minced pork on the inside and she
said this is the best place in the
actual place that we went to last time
is your sister place of this joint so
this place is supposed to be way better
this is milk tea okay I [ __ ] up super
bad because we're actually getting the
milk tea the boba place now I haven't
gotten boba here in Taiwan which is
blasphemy because that's where Boba's
from we're at the motherland we're at
the tip of the vagina the the pink dick
of Taiwan Muriel was insisting that we
get whap out here now the guava place
here is actually the main place and we
actually got it before at the sister
places she was telling me how delicious
was and how no matter how good that
other place is this one with ten times
better so you had to come here and get
this you know that pillowy delicious
porky fatty goodness and of course we
got some corn soup to go along with that
and to wash it down we got that
delicious moment that we got earlier so
let's give this a go my friends
yeah yeah
baboso good it's if you're allergic to
peanuts I'm [ __ ] sorry I hope it's a
sweet soft pillowy bun the fatty part
the sweet meat the cilantro that adds a
nice little herb a bite to it
some of these like pickled marinated
vegetables time on you have me by the
penis in the stomach this is the corn
soup famous corn soup it's like a
constant a very clear Bob oh yeah oh
that is a if you guys had a creamy corn
chowder before that's exactly what it
tastes like but it's not heavy from all
the cream and the fat that's added from
the dairy it's just really clear very
clean on the palate but corn flavor
enough max oh this is milk tea with boba
I don't know what makes it so special
but I'm not to find out that's friggin
good dude there's almost like a mild
coffee a lot of the things that we have
it's very overpowering right it goes too
sweet it's too bitter
I feel like this drink is a perfect
medium a bitter sweet and creamy I love
this this is amazing
I'm gonna live right on this order they
eat this every day cheers [ __ ]
[Music]